-Our next guest will be
at The Improv in
Irvine, California,
January 10th.
Making his "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome
the very funny Fumi Abe!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you. It's good to be here.
My name is Fumi.
I speak Japanese,
but I grew up in America,
so the Japanese that I speak,
I mainly learned it
through textbooks.
So what that means
is my Japanese --
it's not bad,
but it's very formal.
And I realized the other day,
it is so formal
that even when I'm on a date
with a Japanese girl
and I'm trying to hook up,
I just sound like
I'm trying to get her
to sign
the Treaty of Versailles.
Like, I was out
with this girl recently.
We were dancing at the club,
and she says to me,
in a very sexy way, "Do you like
the way that feels?"
And what I wanted to say is,
"Yes, it feels amazing,"
but what came out of my mouth
was, "I derive many pleasures."
She was like, "Okay,
I guess the war is over.
I don't know --
I don't know what that means."
I started comedy
when I was 24 years old,
and I remember
when I first started,
my parents were very concerned.
So, I'll never forget this.
I remember they sat me down,
and they had
a little "talk" with me.
They were like,
"Hey, Fumi, listen,
we think you're making
a huge mistake, alright?
First of all, you're not even
the funniest person
in the family, okay?
Grandma -- way funnier, okay?
Second of all,
there is no money in comedy.
How are you going to pay
for stuff in New York?
It's very expensive.
We think you're gonna
look back 10 years from now
and say to yourself,
'Where did my career go wrong?'"
And I took that
really personally.
But then I moved to New York
and I started making friends
who are my age,
who are musicians, comedians,
artists who were so rich.
And I realized
they're not rich
because they're famous
or successful.
They're rich because
their parents are rich, right?
And their parents
pay for everything.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, you guys know
people like that, right?
Right? Yeah.
You know those people who, like,
go get massages
without using a Groupon?
You what I'm talking about?
These heathens.
And I started making
so many friends like this
that, one day,
I just had this thought.
I was like, "Dude, if I meet
one more person like that,
I'm going to have to
sit my parents down
and have a little talk
with them
about where their careers
went wrong."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because they're looking at me
like, "Why are you so poor?"
I'm like, "I'm poor
because you're poor.
That is why I'm poor, okay?
Why don't you go to
law school, okay?
You go. Why don't you go?"
One thing about having
immigrant parents
is that they don't know
a lot about money,
so they never taught me
how to build wealth.
So now, as an adult,
whenever I get money,
I don't know how to invest,
I don't know how to spend it,
I don't know how
to be rich with it,
and it's kind of embarrassing.
Like, recently,
I did this corporate show
with my two comedian friends.
We made a lot of money.
We're talking about
how we spent this money.
And I found out
one of my friends
put a down payment on a Tesla.
The other guy bought
two Rolex watches.
And they looked at me
and they're like,
"Fumi, how did you
spend that money?"
And I was thinking about it.
And I'm not making this up.
The only thing I started doing
with that money is,
I just started buying, like, the
nicer rice at the grocery store.
Yeah. You know that premium one
that's like 10 more dollars
than the one you typically buy?
Isn't that sad?
Like, literally,
my comedian friends
are prancing around
in their Gucci loafers,
and I'm just eating a rice ball
at lunch, being like,
"Notice anything different?"
[ Applause ]
I don't know.
I think about money a lot
because I'm a Millennial,
and I feel like our whole thing
is that we work very hard,
but we don't have a ton of money
in the bank account
because the economy
keeps messing with us, right?
Like, let me ask you something.
Clap if you're a Millennial.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
Now clap if you're a Millennial
and you own a house.
[ Light applause ]
Okay.
Those are all tourists.
Those are all tourists, okay?
They're all from Ohio.
We know that. We know that.
And you know how I know that?
Because every time I do
this joke in New York or L.A.,
people just start
crying immediately,
and the show is over.
But that makes me sad
that only like three people own.
That makes me so sad,
because I know
you guys all work really hard,
and I feel --
That silence that just happened?
I feel like that's
the reason why, today --
You know how every
young person today
is trying out,
like, a polyamorous,
ethically non-monogamous,
open relationship or whatever?
I don't even think we're having
a sexual awakening.
I think we just realize,
as a generation,
that we need
a few more guys to go in
on a down payment
on a house, right?
Like, we are not horny, okay?
It's just that me and my girl --
we don't make enough,
so we have to add
a white guy who loves anime.
You guys have been amazing.
Thank you so much.
I've been Fumi Abe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God! Well done.
Fumi! Fumi Abe!
He'll be at the Irvine Improv
January 10th.